on est là pour aider les gens à
mamodtaky
louis fait les parents est ambulancier
chez urgences santé depuis quinze ans il
observe que les conditions de travail de
ses collègues se sont détériorées au fil
des années en raison du manque
d'ambulance y est les heures
supplémentaires obligatoires font
maintenant partie du quotidien car ça
fait déjà douze heures qui est sur place
tes journées se rassemblant 14 la
pénurie de travailleurs n'a pourtant
rien de nouveau le syndicat des
ambulanciers la dénoncent depuis
plusieurs mois mais voilà que ses
conséquences sont maintenant bien réel
on est inquiet parce qu'on vient de
frapper le mur et c'est pas le premier
décès malheureusement
une dame de 91 ans a perdu la vie
quelques jours après avoir attendu les
ambulanciers durant sept heures
effectivement il ya une chatte heures de
délai beaucoup trop d'appels urgents par
cette part à musique est-ce que ça a été
trop long je t'ai fait il valoir en cas
de car à l'heure dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche sur le territoire d'urgences
santé seulement 55 paramédics étaient
déployés sur le terrain alors qu'il en
aurait fallu 98 les ambulanciers
craignent d'autres tragédies
actuellement on va se dire cumul
sur près de 120 candidatures reçues par
urgences santé depuis le début de
l'année - une quarantaine ont été
retenus c'est trop peu selon le syndicat
qui réclame l'embauché d'une centaine de
paramédics supplémentaires pour
permettre aux ambulanciers de reprendre
leur souffle on peut pas gérer une
compagnie d'ambulances comme si à 24 à
strophes
quatre fois par jour
autour de la marche appelle tous ses
membres à ne plus se priver de leur
pause repas en guise de moyen de
pression urgences-santé appréhende les
conséquences de ce geste ce savant
neirynck rien délai pour ma part ils ont
sondé apec sont non urgents le syndicat
des ambulanciers exige que les heures
supplémentaires de ses membres soient
rémunérés à tout double une solution
parmi tant d'autres pour pallier la
pénurie il supplie le gouvernement de
débloquer les fonds nécessaires avant
que notre drame frappe sans prévenir ici
a dit alcine radio canada montréal